thank you
hello and welcome to this unusual AI
coffee break today we'll give you a
teaser about some of our own work which
was accepted at ACL Toronto 2023 we will
present it in July so if you happen to
be at ACL in Toronto do not hesitate to
say hi so here we'll leave you with a
bit of what we have recorded to present
our paper
hello we are happy to present our work
on MM shap a reliable way to measure
relative contributions of individual
modalities in multimodal models why is
measuring multimodal contributions
important vision and language models
have better and better performance
across all possible VL tasks but can we
trust that it do this for the right
reasons fundamentally these models are
Transformers that work on text and image
input they are trained for example with
the image sentence alignment objective
to say whether a pair of texts and
images match or mismatch now there is
reason to believe that not all
modalities matter for these models
equally since they can suffer from any
model collapsed this means that even if
trained multimodally a model can exploit
one modality far more than the other and
indeed we observe that on multimodal
tasks unimodal Baseline can be close in
accuracy to multimodal models the
reasons are often data set biases for
example how many questions can be
confidently answered with two if two is
the most frequent answer in the data set
or if questions about existence of an
object can be typically answered with
yes due to the so-called plausibility
bias previous work has used model
performance to assess a model's focus on
a modality for example by testing
whether it is sensitive to changing
matching image caption pairs into
mismatching ones or by measuring whether
their accuracy changes when exchanging
existing images with random ones and
questions for vqa with random questions
or by deleting image regions or text
tokens and measuring whether model
performance changes but accuracy-based
measures are not ideal for example the
visual importance considers the
difference in model accuracy when it
used both visual and text and with
missing visual information this is
problematic for wrong model predictions
since in these cases the first term is
zero and we expect the second term to be
0 2 and this results in a visual
importance of zero but the model May
well have relied on the visual modality
but incorrectly so we propose a
performance agnostic measure of
multimodal contributions first we rely
on sharply values from Game Theory
Sharpie values compute a fair payout for
each player based on their contribution
to A Game's outcome for example if
machine learning were a soccer game we
would first assess the base value which
is the game outcome when no player is
playing then we gradually let them play
and measure in all possible combinations
of teams from our available players what
a game outcomes are and we determine how
much payment they deserve for
Transformers the players are tokens and
they receive payouts from their
contribution towards the model
prediction for example the probability
or activation valued computed for a
sample irrespective of whether its
prediction is correct or not we take the
difference between the model output with
the token being active and with it
inactive and we do this for all possible
combinations of tokens switched on and
off
to get the contributions for a token
which can be positive or negative we sum
up and normalize over all marginal
contributions for vision and language
Transformers we have image tokens and
text tokens and we can compute their
contribution towards the model
prediction such as the image sentence
alignment score and luckily none of
those computations are accuracy based we
Define mm shap by calculating the
contribution percentage of text tokens
and compare it to the contribution
percentage of image tokens which can be
extended to multiple modalities for
image sentence alignment we hypothesize
that image and tags contribute equally
on average at Corpus level because it is
useful when comparing different models
on the same task and data using mm shap
on Sample level we see how image and
text tokens contribute towards the
predicted 99 image sentence alignment
score in blue and tokens that
contributed against in red introducing
an error in the caption decreases the
alignment score and the token
contributions reflect the misalignment
with the token keyboard showing negative
contribution a data set and task level
we see that models such as clip are
multimodally balanced while albeff
models are more textually focused this
Trends holds over vqa as well and on the
vast Benchmark testing models with
fine-grained mismatches we see even
better that clip is balanced lxmert has
a higher visual preference while album
models are more textual showing that
different VL models behave differently
on the same task fine-tuning also
affects multimodal contributions and
with mmshap we can measure how much even
in cases where task accuracy is very low
and accuracy base metrics would fail
throughout our analysis we consistently
plotted both accuracy and mmshap scores
because we envision mm shap to
complement accuracy not replace it since
we are of course interested in how well
models solve a task but it's only by
using accuracy agnostic metrics such as
mm shap that we can measure how much
models rely on each modality we invite
you to read our paper for more details
thanks for sticking until the very end
of this it's great to see somebody is
interested in the work I do for my PhD
you know it's not much but it's honest
work and if you like this maybe you like
other videos on our Channel if you like
work from large companies with huge
collaborations then maybe you want to
check out The Velo to see how neural
networks can work as optimizers for
other networks possibly replacing Adam
or if you would rather have something by
smaller collaborations maybe check out
this one a watermark for large language
models and maybe the paella diffusion
model in any case we hope to see you
next time
bye
[Music]
foreign